[Music]
in not surprised news never surprised I
knew it was gonna happen
submitted by Corgi con logic businessman
is suing his mistress to recover two
million dollars she willingly gave her
you stupid [ __ ] god I would want my
money back - and the OL amuse story it's
stupid [ __ ]
alright so this takes place in Singapore
Singapore mistresses or the [ __ ] know
Wow I'm right here dude as long as you
don't go to Singapore all relations
gonna be good you me as long as you
don't go to Singapore no she doesn't
meet them I have a lot of trips to
Singapore mmm I want to go to Singapore
not for those reasonable kind of Asia
mistress it is that you feel so much
occasion power there no I'm first of all
it's really really small like The
Stepford Wives of Asia
I don't watch Stepford Wives so I can't
really it's just a movie got it I just I
meant that in a way that like everything
is so clean and everything is so yeah
like you can't be like don't cigarette
butts you can't like spit your gum you
speak gum you shouldn't be doing that
regardless no but you could go to you
could get fine to go to jail doesn't
work here I know be a decent human being
anyway Singapore is beautiful you should
go to jail for spitting gum on the floor
I agree yeah so this story here is
around this guy who's 55 years old and
he gave two million Singapore dollars to
his mistress which turns out to be 1.4
million
I'll let once like what did he go up
whop whop yo out their love affair she
got out this was in the period of three
months so he gave her oh god damn that's
a big come up yeah like for why should I
go to Singapore - I think so okay we'll
just
you get your [ __ ] I'll get my dude yeah
opposite sides is like 30 minutes away
from each other by the way okay
[ __ ] whoring each other yeah giving
each other money his mistress by the way
is 33 years old and so she was clean
he's even choose good mistresses even
that's all heard it from your mouth
great jokes great jokes alright so then
he said that he is claiming that the
money he gave her was a loan and
therefore it must be repairs the
document where's the written proof so
they do have her improve oh but the
mistress is saying that that written
proof was all a facade because all this
[ __ ] tripping because he was in the
middle or he was about to get divorced
with his wife and so that's he asked her
like hey can we write up this contract
between both of our lawyers saying that
I'm gonna let you borrow the money so my
wife doesn't ask for stocks in our
shares in my business and so it's good
at divorce so then that's the reason why
he sued over two women at once well he
has been divorced before oh that's what
a seasoned he is a seasoned divorcee so
then that's when so the mistress is
claiming that he said that and then
added but this two million is a gift to
you know you can have it vocally he said
that it was a key smart yeah okay I
called you stupid [ __ ] your dick and I
take it back you're not a stupid [ __ ]
your dick your smart ass dick yeah yes
so then um he is now suing her for that
oh by the way she ended up getting
pregnant by this dude oh that's nice
she's not stupid either
yeah she's mine
[ __ ] so the the husband was saying that
he was gonna give three million dollars
to his wife and some other stuff just as
a saying like alright hurting gift
pretty much because it's like you didn't
give me any children this is a childless
marriage so go away that's what he was
doing right so it turns out though that
this check the mistress has two children
from a previous marriage he's a property
owner
she's prostitute previous marriages from
millionaires to the plot you make is so
they say they write that she owns two
properties and earns as much as seventy
thousand annually yeah [ __ ] I'm sorry
seven hundred thousand there's an extra
zero there they're just all ballers
they're all look at the bother class
this is why we crazy rich Asians is
about so this is another game I don't
remember how he said she got pregnant
well after she got pregnant she was
trying to get in touch with this gold
and he ghosted her smart move
wait the one that the one that loan lent
her the money oh yeah the man never
cheated ghosting her yeah oh you just
want to be the daddy he's smart he's
playing the right divorce moves they're
all sorry it's really confusing because
he said I'll give you another million I
think it was if you have a daughter
it was weird what what oh he wanted a
daughter yeah I don't know it's really
odd so then he stands up saying or
writing that to millions he said give
birth to a daughter and we'll have a
reward of two million reward what what
if it's a son man so she's like an heir
to his throne but it's a daughter can't
be I don't know maybe somewhere deja
[ __ ] Oh No so he did text her these
things right so the like her lawyers
have proof of the messages here and that
he was being very friendly with her even
after he he was like trying to sue her
for the money back but anyway so when
she found out that he was suing her for
her to repay
two million that he initially gave her
that's like soon after is when she had a
miscarriage
whoa this is that soap opera see this is
why I need my popcorn yeah
prop corn so yeah yes so then now
they're saying now both parties are
claiming that the loan agreement is
invalid and so she well she's claiming
it was invalid because of the whole fact
that he's saying that it was a gift but
for him he was claiming that he made the
agreement agreement while he was under
his former mistress's undue influence
and that the terms of the contract were
unfair to him the [ __ ] power he was
under the [ __ ] caucus [ __ ] quoted
Wizardry who was like I was I've never
spell that puss it was too good your
honor do you understand good yo I had a
[ __ ] I know I know what you mean you're
not guilty a corrupt judge that also was
under wizardry three years ago yeah but
the same lady she was all her [ __ ] game
too strong man that Singapore and [ __ ]
so that's the story now the case
contends crazy oh my god I just I hear
these stories of like rich people
[ __ ] just popping out babies and like
doing all this deceitful [ __ ] and like
getting an album alimony pay and all
that stuff and like that's the whole
heist in itself if you had to choose one
drama getting divorced to a having a
really bad divorce and both of y'all are
ballin or having a really bad divorce in
both of y'all are porous but poor all
the way really can't take [ __ ] from me
hey you can get ghetto and scratch cars
and [ __ ] such a less pride it's such
a less sophisticated breakup that I
think it's just way easier like if it's
like two homeless people it's like imma
cut our cardboard box down the middle
you get this side I get this side and
boom is the experience of the divorce
because like at the end of it divorce
both really rich
are you like at the other invoice you
still rich but there's just so much [ __ ]
now because now you have where as if I'm
poor or through my divorce one I'm going
I'm so poor yeah but I'm already
thinking about the future see but it's
so like when I'm broke right let's say
you're you're broke right what's the
best [ __ ] you move is after you get
divorced you become rich papa but if
you're if you're [ __ ] rich and then
you both lose that money then you both
broke in sad we don't both lose it one
person gets it right there's a kid
involved in this oh [ __ ] I've kid you
know what forget it
no but that's I'm saying that's what and
her I pathetic laughter I'm saying when
you're simple when you're when you're
rich there's just so much more SH like
if you own 20 properties across the
nation now you have to equalize the
value of it like is the mansion in the
Hamptons the same as the small beach
house in Malibu and then you got boats
and [ __ ] this it's [ __ ] crazy
that's true it when your prop when
you're [ __ ] poor all you do is split
that last flamin hot cheeto in half
that's all and no honestly for me though
I'm so [ __ ] lazy and I'm just like
listen if this is gonna get ugly just
take it take everything I don't give a
[ __ ] not if you assume a divorce yeah
you got you time over money she's like
[ __ ] it
yeah your kids your kids and everything
would they take everything you're just
nothing is left believe that Isaac Isaac
that's a lady no you mind he's not going
to the negotiation dead if I was evil
Casey I'd like
if you get Isaac then I get the house
yep
listen I rather play but but I have
Isaac I need the house and buy what
Isaac means a lot to me too
so what do you want so God gets [ __ ]
comments in at that point I'll work hard
to just make it work make the marriage
work I thought you were lazy
no you just say lazy I just not because
I was a child of a very very bitter
divorce so I don't want to put my kid
that's why I was asking like is there a
child involved in this whatever is the
easiest way out that the kid doesn't
suffer as much as other routes that's
the one well you turned out great well I
think if we divorce I don't know if I
would marry again oh I forgot to mention
my favorite part about this whole sorry
well it was about to see something
really sweet but it's ours I'm so sorry
and okay I don't get these often but I
mean I love you too much oh you know I
love you know what took it away I
thought you say that person I'll tell
you might think he said something about
like I wouldn't marry again make it up
right I had a beautiful haiku plan done
it's all gone now I apologize okay it
only comes in once in a hundred years
romance it's like an eclipse you know
but that's aligned
I don't even wanna tell you anymore cuz
I have too much and I ruined too much of
the conversation okay well the
expectations guys i it's just that one
of the lawyers name was Anthony Lee
that's it that was what the romance
being taken away cuz I just pictured him
in a kynges outfit like a part-time
doing lawyer [ __ ] in Singapore again
because you were just dancing and you're
a busy man you know like [ __ ] am i right
yeah which way which way is it now the
one yeah it what does this mean though
more swag oh hey the bird
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]